in Butcher on the outskirts of Kiev
Valentina watches as Builders repair her
home it was damaged by shelling when
Russian forces occupied the town last
year an experience she says was worse
than living through World War II
everything was destroyed the TV sofa
clothes I couldn't stay so I went to my
neighbor's basement we spent weeks there
there were explosions night and day
Russians and ukrainians firing I don't
know how I survived to you
the house now has new windows and soon
the roof will be finished Valentina
sweeps up shavings from the timber to
fuel her burner
butcher's Town Council is financing
reconstruction in this neighborhood one
of many districts pounded by Russian
Artillery
every house in the street has been
damaged and it's a similar picture in so
many parts of Ukraine it is clear that
rebuilding the country is going to take
years and cost a lot of money
as the war continues in Ukraine so does
the destruction mangled infrastructure
and bombarded buildings are now part of
the landscape some people are forced to
survive in what's left of their homes
Kiev estimates that reconstruction will
cost at least 350 billion dollars the EU
has an idea about how it could be funded
Ukraine will rebuild
and the damages must be compensated if
we have only Frozen over 300 billion
euros of Russian assets I am strongly
convinced this shoots and this will be
used for you trains for construction
not all EU members are convinced about
using Frozen Russian assets for
Ukraine's reconstruction but some say it
would be a form of Justice making Moscow
pay to rebuild what it has destroyed
even though no amount of money could
ever fully restore people's shattered
lives
Natasha Butler Al Jazeera butcher
Ukraine